it's a warm but beautiful evening in
kansas city where we come to you from
kauffman stadium for royals baseball 90
degrees outside and on the mound for the
royals making his
185th career start danny duffy opponents
only hitting 170 off danny this year and
despite that he is owen two and he
strikes him out went right after with
that fastball that really was electric
against the chicago cubs earlier this
week
he strikes out nelson cruz and a
beautiful first inning for danny duffy
we head to the bottom of the first danny
duffy looking sharp jacob rizzy making
his first start of the 2020 season he's
made his major league debut as a member
of the kansas city royals back on
september 23rd 2012.
now o'hearn
back up the middle that's a base hit
meripel will score they're going to hold
perez at third base and o'hearn comes
through he is now seven for 11 with
runners in scoring position he tried to
sneak a piece of cheese by a hungry rat
and that's not going to happen we showed
you his average with runners in scoring
position
you know in mcbroom the guy he's
platooning with the first base is
hitting homers this is o'hearn's turn
he's like
i'm not going to let him take my job top
of the third inning here duffy towing
the slab here at the k a beautiful yard
how about that
chase
oh you got to reach for it fell for it
that was nice got him off balance salvi
good job by danny duffy shutting out the
minnesota twins through three innings
solaire leads off the royals third
inning
and solaire busted
deep to left that's a way back
and he got all of that split change oh
my goodness he hit it off of the royals
hall of fame
[Applause]
fizz that just sucked the wind out of
the cave that that was a blast i mean a
line shot
[Applause]
oh man i can't breathe up here
oxygen please
heir solaire is at it again
and the 2-1 pitch a fly ball into right
center field and deep byron going back
on the track jumps at the wall makes the
catch leaves the ground with both feet
hit the wall pretty hard but gets the
ball back in for the second out
so byron smiling as he's on his feet but
that is the new style danny that he's
been practicing
he left the ground on the warning track
with both feet not the one foot made the
catch and still
that head collided with the padding in
right center field
do nothing kansas city would go to the
fourth inning will be nelson cruz
leading off drive to center field
deep to center field and there she goes
a home run for nelson cruz his fourth of
the year and the twins are on the board
another no doubter we saw solaire's home
run that got out in a hurry but
duffy reacted he knew instantly you see
it's a circle change but it stays up
runner at second base in gonzales he's
the tying run the batter gonna be byron
buxton now three and two
a high fly deep down the line towards
the bowl got it and
gone a home run for the third game in a
row
this time with two men aboard and the
twins take the lead a breaking ball
and buxton waited on it and got it stay
hot byron that's three games in a row
that is homer and that is the first time
in his career three games in a row
and the royals will bring the tying run
to the plate how about nikki lopez
hit pretty well to right field that's
way back and that ball is
a goner how about this nikki lopez does
tie it up joel
how about that
vicky lopez taking a slider from a
left-hander hang it you hang it and
he'll bang it oh my gosh look at it
great stiff leg their front side good
balance on the swing bat
barrel came through
snuck it over the wall get the royals
right back in it and help danny duffy
big time see if solaire can do his job
now the infielders on the left side a
little nervous
cracks it high in the air that's deep to
center that's a way back and that ball's
away gone
that's impressive right after minnesota
dropped four on duffy in the top of this
inning the royals just come right back
with home runs show their power oh
that ball was hit in the solaire system
look at that high breaking ball on a t
for solaire and he muscled it dead
center field almost
hitting the hydration station that's his
seventh career multi-home run game
five in the inning still nobody out here
salvador perez trying to get a new rally
started nobody on
oh my nose and
salvador perez
hits one on the nose and blasts it out
of here
he
just uncorked it that's a
straightforward seamer that he did not
miss and after solaire
whoo
sally's turn
how about that a sick spot the royals
have put up in the fourth inning here
and the boys are liking it
bases are loaded for minnesota with
buxton coming up who has been really hot
lately
line to left field that will get in one
they will hold the runner at third base
it's an eight to five score
and the bottom of the order has been
just chewing up the royals tonight
we'll bring up max kepler
and a drive right field going back is
cordero at the wall and it's gone what
an at-bat for max kepler
and the twins hit another home run
they're third tonight
and they're back within two
split finger
and you see it just sail away a little
bit and ultimately it ends up speeding
up his battle a little bit look at how
he gets the barrel out front
up the middle
i mean they had no chance of getting him
anyway he's so fast down that line oh
yeah that's a that's an easy base hit
there modesty goes pitch taken throw by
garver not in time
there he goes
no throw
i mean he had such a huge jump
gets away and here comes monday and
that's an important
ninth run to give the royals a three-run
lead
boy is that an example of speed he
manufactured that run by himself infield
hit two stolen bases scoring in a wild
pitch
we have achieved the ninth inning the
royals lead 9-6
so kepler with a couple of hits and he's
kept the game alive for cruz
they ring them up and the royals win the
first two games of this series
they have their first series victory
over the minnesota twins
since september of 2018.